Why Do Olympians Wear Colored Tape?
The colored tape the Olympians and other athletes
wear is called “Kinesio® Tex Tape”, which
is essentially just an elastic cotton strip
with an acrylic, heat activated adhesive.
The tape was designed in the 1970s by a Japanese
chiropractic and acupuncture specialist, Kenzo
Kase.
To date, there hasn’t been a single reputable
study that conclusively shows this tape actually
does anything the makers and athletes claim
it does, though as Kevin Anderson, director
of Kinesio UK, states “There’s a lot more
needed on the research side to confirm the
positive results we’re seeing so far.”
(In truth, there have been numerous studies
in the over 30 years this tape has been around
and so far the results of using the tape have
been more or less in-line with the placebo
effect.
It’s interesting that the company itself
can make such claims when they apparently
have not done research themselves to back
them despite being around for over 30 years;
otherwise, I’d assume Mr. Anderson would
be citing said research, rather than saying
research is needed.)
So to answer your question as to why Olympians
and other athletes are wearing colored tape
– because they think it helps in some medically
significant way.
The lack of evidence to support this never
stopped athletes from wearing Phiten bracelets/necklaces
or Power Balance holographic bracelets, which
in their heyday both got amazing reviews from
athletes as to the performance benefits, only
to go out of fashion when it was conclusively
shown that they didn’t do anything (and
when the sponsorship dollars to said athletes
dried up).
So it’s not surprising that Kinesio tape
has become popular; it certainly seems more
believably beneficial than an over priced
plastic bracelet with a holographic sticker
on it.
Further, the placebo benefit is potentially
better than nothing.
Basically, if nothing else, it’s probably
good in such athletic competitions to think
you have a slight edge… the power of positive
thinking and all that.
As Amy Powell, associate professor of sports
medicine at the University of Utah School
of Medicine said in a recent interview, “Anything
that [athletes] perceive as an edge, they’ll
try, whether it’s scientific or not.
And the athletes are convinced that [Kinesio
tape] is really helpful.
It wouldn’t be the worst placebo in the
world; it’s not doing any harm.”
As mentioned, this tape has been around for
a while, even seen in the Olympics since 1988,
but has only relatively recently become widely
popular among athletes after Kinesio very
wisely donated 50,000 rolls of their tape
to be used by various Olympians from 58 countries
during the 2008 Olympic Games.
They also switched gears from primarily offering
skin colored tape to pushing other colors.
They say on their website, “The colors were
developed to be compatible with color therapy…”
Yep, color therapy.
And, more accurate and surprisingly candid,
they go on to state the colors were made to
“provide field advertising at athletic events,
a conversational opener, and instant product
recognition.”
According to sports chiropractor and strength
and conditioning specialist, Chad Peters,
they also “paid [Olympic volleyball player]
Kerri Walsh to wear black tape instead of
flesh tones in Beijing.
After that, it just exploded.
Everybody wanted it.”
Specifically, after the Beijing games, sales
skyrocketed to 300% of what they were before
and Kinesio tape has become “must use”
by athletes the world over.
As to what the tape is supposed to do, this
is from the Kinesio website,
In cases of injury or overuse, the muscle
loses its elasticity.
Dr. Kase needed to develop a tape that would
have the same elasticity as healthy human
muscle.
He knew from his practice that the tape would
also need to stay on the skin where it was
applied.
He spent two years doing a lot of research
relating to elasticity, adhesives and breathability.
Finally, he came up with a tape that possessed
the proper degree of elasticity, and that
lifts the skin microscopically.
From that beginning, Kinesio® Tex Tape was
invented.
Its unique properties were based on a study
of kinesiology.
Kinesio® Tex Tape is used to
Re-educate the neuromuscular system
Reduce pain
Optimize performance
Prevent injury
Promote improved circulation and healing
…Kinesio® Tex Tape is used to treat anything
from headaches to foot problems and everything
in between.
As to the inspiration behind the tape, Kenzo
Kase states, “Our pain sensors are located
between the epidermis and the dermis, the
first and second layers of your skin, so I
thought that if I applied tape to the pain,
it would lift the epidermis slightly up and
make a space between the two layers.”
To date, the main study that is often cited
seeming to indicate that the Kinesio tape
actually does any of these things better than
a placebo is The Clinical Efficacy of Kinesio
Tape for Shoulder Pain: A randomized, Double-blinded,
Clinical Trial.
Unfortunately for Kinesio, there are quite
a lot of problems with the way this study
was done and even then the results don’t
say what many media outlets are saying it
does.
The first questionable aspect of the study
is the fact that its primary author is a certified
Kinesio taping practitioner and someone who
has applied for two patents for Kinesio-type
tape.
Granted, in a study like this, you need a
Kinesio expert to apply the tape, but it brings
up the question of bias when the primary author
has great interest in the study providing
a positive result.
It would be better to simply hire a Kinesio
expert to apply the tape and have independent
parties actually perform the study.
Nevertheless, just because a certified Kinesio
Taping practitioner was the primary author,
if his methods were sound, we can’t throw
out the results altogether.
So were there any other problems with the
study?
In a word, yes.
64 people were initially eligible for this
study, with applicable shoulder problems,
but 22 were weeded out as “an attempt to
eliminate subjects with pathology that would
be less likely to respond to the selected
taping intervention.”
While it is good to weed out subjects that
aren’t fit for what you’re studying, weeding
them out because “they would be less likely
to respond to the selected taping intervention”
sounds an awful lot like trying to fix the
results, not selecting from “randomized”
test subjects, as the title implies.
Again, not conclusively showing bias, as maybe
they really did weed out subjects simply because
they weren’t fit for the study, but their
wording sounds fishy.
Further, such a small sample-size is also
questionable, in terms of actually providing
conclusive results, positive or negative,
unless there was a clear, strong contrast
between the control and the test subjects.
This brings us to the real problem with this
study.
There is no control group.
Both the “control” group and the test
subjects had Kinesio tape applied.
The only difference was that one group had
the tape correctly applied, based on the methods
taught to Kinesio taping practitioners, the
other group had it incorrectly applied, but
it was the same Kinesio tape both times.
This might be proper if studying the benefits
of one method of applying the tape vs. another,
but not to study whether the elastic tape
actually does something or not.
Again, as with the small sample size, whether
the results came out positive, negative, or
inconclusive, one can hardly take them seriously
in this context.
And, in fact, their so-called “control”
group showed similar results as the ones given
the correct taping method.
Specifically, the final results of this study
can be summed up (though in a much more glowing
way in the paper, highlighting initial possible
differences within the first 48 hours that
went away after) as: some people got better,
some people got worse with the correctly taped
group, and some people got better and some
worse with the incorrectly taped group.
Or, as they state in the paper, “The improvement
noted in both groups makes it difficult to
determine any specificity of effect the intended
therapeutic tape application may have had
over the sham application for all outcome
measures in this study.”
Despite the results explicitly being inconclusive,
the small sample size, the potential bias
of the author, and the lack of control group,
this paper is often cited in the media as
conclusively showing the tape was beneficial
for helping with shoulder problems.
I was going to write about a few additional
studies on the effects (or often lack thereof)
of Kinesio tape, but this article’s already
about 10 times longer than I anticipated it
would be and I’m guessing there are about
zero people that made it this far.
But just in case I’m wrong, I’ll refer
you few brave souls that waded through the
last 1500 words or so, and for some odd reason
want more, to several linked studies at the
top of the References below if you’d like
to read up more on studies pertaining to Kinesio
tape, including one such study that simply
looked at 97 other studies on Kinesio tape’s
“effectiveness”.
For the most part, they all seem to conclude
with something to the effect of “Use of
the tape doesn’t seem to produce clinically
significant results, but more rigorous testing
is needed to be sure.”
But a few are very slightly more positive,
leaning towards thinking there is at least
some benefit, even if not what the company
claims, though again tending to state that
more rigorous testing is needed to be sure
and to test whether any type of tape would
have the same benefit.
So in the end, is Kinesio tape actually beneficial
with respect to “reducing pain, optimizing
performance, preventing injury, promoting
improved circulation and healing, and re-educating
the neuromuscular system”?
Probably not, at least not for all those claims,
but the placebo effect can’t be ignored
completely in terms of perhaps providing some
benefit to athletes, if they believe the tape
works.
And, who knows?
Maybe someday someone will prove that Kinesio
tape really is beneficial beyond what would
be expected with the placebo effect, possibly
even lining up with some of their claims!
Stranger things have happened and the use
of an elastic tape to help support inflamed
or sore body parts as they move seems like
it probably could be helpful, just perhaps
not at treating “anything from headaches
to foot problems and everything in between”.
As Dr. David Geier, orthopedic surgeon and
director of sports medicine at the Medical
University of South Carolina stated, “If
there is structural damage like a torn ACL
or meniscus, it’s not going to be effective;
after all, it’s tape.”